pas que surtout en confinement est un
moment très particulier unique pour
toute la planète en tout cas une grande
partie de la planète et pour les
catholiques aussi bien entendu qu'aucun
la toute première pâques était vécu en
egypte à la libération des esclaves
étaient une pac en confinement puisque
chaque maisonnée devaient se rassembler
dans la maison et ne pas sentir déjà
donc il ya plusieurs milliers d'années
et c'est à ce moment là que les hébreux
ont véritablement été libérés de
l'esclavagé bien pour nous les chrétiens
cette année ce sera un moment très
particulier comme beaucoup d'autres bien
sûr mais on on à vivre des grands
moments liturgique tout seul ou plutôt
en méconnaissant se rassembler comme on
a coutume de le faire
ce sont un peu bizarres bon via les
médias et les moyens de communication
sociale les les réseaux sociaux les
radios tv etc qui permettront de rester
en communion spirituelle mais on le sera
déjà et puis ce sera l'occasion de
célébrer pâte aussi en confinement c'est
à dire en famille peut-être sans
forcément des moyens de la communication
avec une bible avec des gestes simples
le renouvellement du baptême un vigile
pascale et avant ça on aura fédéré
lacroix méditer sur le sacrifice jésus
le vendredi saint et puis avancer un
goal de 10,1 sur le grand moment il a
institué la messe l'eucharistie ou
l'institut aussi les prêtres dans le
monde pour célébrer le kite
donc voilà trois grands moments et puis
le bouquet final ce sera aussi le
dimanche de pâques alors m'a invité les
familles à à faire la fête aussi à un
peu par un bon repas préparé les
gâteries dès le samedi
gloria ou soit déjà peau pour célébrer
la pâte en famille ce soit un moment
fort mais ça aurait déjà été pour les
rares moments forts beaucoup de familles
mais ce sera le cas aussi cette fois ci
pour pâques
voilà j'espère que tous